so how did Kevin Smith and the SModcast
get involved with alter egos and what
kind of support do they offer I have no
idea I I don't know how to get involved
they wouldn't be they have Kevin Smith
SModcast has a deal with phase four who
acquired our film and they are
partnering up on a certain number of
films and so again Kevin you know Smith
has tweeted about it a number of times
which I think you know he's got a legion
of fans but I don't know specifically
you know how much how much Kevin has
personally been involved me I know
putting his name on it is one of the
first things most people even mentioned
to me about the movie so that just in
and of itself has been a major boost for
the movie that's just him saying Kevin
Smith presents putting it on a poster
put another trailer people get very
excited he's got a really dedicated
group of folks that follow him and love
him and you know we're waiting for
whatever he's you know got coming next
so that's been nice and I think he's
looking for now on his career from what
I understand is that he's trying to help
push and and generate younger filmmakers
that kind of kind of happy started and
so Jordan Galland is is kind of one of
those and I think he's excited about
Kevin's been excited about me
you know like Chris Hedges his legion of
fans and and that that's really helped
us I think for sure
have either of you been to this mod
counseling the smart Castle I didn't
know there was such a thing it's a small
castle what does
you